Traductor:
Revisor: Almudena Torrecilla
Aquí en este bosque frondoso,
Malassezia está equipada con todo
lo que alguna vez podría necesitar.
Dándose continuos festines,
está en el paraíso.
Pero esperen, ¿de qué se trata?
Malassezia es un tipo de levadura
que vive y come
en nuestros cueros cabelludos.
Y en casi la mitad de la población humana,
su actividad provoca caspa.
Entonces, ¿por qué unas personas
tienen más caspa que otras?
Y, ¿cómo se puede tratar?
Podríamos considerarnos individuos,
pero en realidad somos colonias.
Nuestra piel alberga
miles de millones de microbios.
Malassezia se acomoda en nuestra piel
poco después de nuestro nacimiento.
Los folículos, esas diminutas cavidades
que albergan pelo por todo nuestro cuerpo,
constituyen viviendas
especialmente populares.
A Malassezia le gustan esos escondites
porque contienen glándulas
que segregan un aceite llamado sebo
que se cree que lubrica
y fortalece nuestro cabello.
Malassezia evolucionó para consumir
proteínas y grasas de nuestra piel.
Y debido a sus numerosos
folículos secretores de sebo,
nuestro cuero cabelludo es una de
las zonas más grasas de nuestro cuerpo,
y por tanto, una de las que contiene
mayor cantidad de levaduras.
Según estos hongos toman la grasa
de nuestro cuero cabelludo,
se va formando caspa.
Se debe a que el sebo se compone de
ácidos grasos saturados e insaturados.
Las grasas saturadas
se apilan perfectamente.
Las grasas insaturadas, por otro lado,
contienen dobles enlaces que crean
una torcedura irregular en su estructura.
Malassezia come sebo secretando una enzima
que libera toda la grasa
de los ácidos grasos.
Pero solo consumen las grasas saturadas,
dejando de lado las insaturadas.
Estas sobras de forma irregular
son absorbidas por la piel,
rompiendo su barrera
y permitiendo que el agua se escape.
El cuerpo detecta estas agresiones
y responde a la defensiva,
causando la inflamación
que da a la caspa su picazón.
También hace que las células de la piel
proliferen para reparar la barrera dañada.
Por lo general, la superficie exterior
de nuestra piel, o epidermis,
se renueva por completo
cada dos o tres semanas.
Las células epidérmicas se dividen,
van hacia la superficie, mueren
y forman la capa exterior dura de la piel,
que se desprende gradualmente en
células individuales casi imperceptibles.
Con la caspa, las células se producen
rápidamente para corregir la barrera rota,
lo que significa que no maduran
ni se diferencian adecuadamente.
En cambio, forman grumos grandes
y grasosos alrededor del folículo piloso
que se desprenden como escamas visibles.
Así es como el apetito voraz de Malassezia
y la reacción de nuestro cuerpo
a sus subproductos genera caspa.
Actualmente, la forma más eficaz
de conseguir deshacerse de la caspa
es mediante el uso de antifúngicos
en productos como el champú,
aplicados sobre el cuero cabelludo
para matar a Malassezia.
Para aquellos que tienen caspa,
esta suele ir y venir,
pues las secreciones de sebo
varían a lo largo de la vida
debido a cambios hormonales.
Pero a pesar de que Malassezia
colonice a todos de forma similar,
no todo el mundo tiene caspa.
Algunas personas son más propensas.
Exactamente por qué no está claro.
¿Las personas con caspa tienen
cierta predisposición genética?
¿Su barrera cutánea es más permeable?
Varios científicos están investigando
si las personas con caspa
pierden más agua por el cuero cabelludo,
y si esto es lo que está provocando
la proliferación de células de la piel.
Los investigadores vieron que Malassezia
se comunicaba con el sistema inmunológico
usando pequeñas moléculas de grasa,
las oxilipinas que regulan la inflamación.
Si pudieran descubrir una manera
de inhibir las oxilipinas inflamatorias
y potenciar las antiinflamatorias,
podrían desarrollar nuevos tratamientos.
Los científicos también investigan si
Malassezia puede traernos algún beneficio.
Hipotetizan que la caspa,
que puede resultarnos
incómoda y embarazosa,
constituye una buena fuente
de alimento graso para la levadura.
Pero la caspa no es contagiosa ni
una gran amenaza para nuestra salud,
y Malassezia parece ser experta
en defender su territorio, nuestra piel,
de otros microbios más dañinos
como Staphylococcus aureus.
Mientras los científicos han llegado
al fondo de muchos misterios
acerca de esta enfermedad,
no cabe duda de que
la caspa sigue siendo un dolor de cabeza.